so this week we saw the hero that
started off in ac
from dc being back in black and the clip
quickly broke the internet
nobody knows what it is but we love
superhero costumes and that got me
thinking back to one of the biggest
mysteries surrounding matt reeves
upcoming film
that is what is the bat symbol on the
new batsuit made out of
though it's been over five months since
the first reveal
people still have no idea and there's
more questions surrounding it than one
of jim carrey's
skimpiest riddler costumes fear not
though as
we think we've finally figured it out
and can successfully say what it is
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing what the chess piece is made
out of
and why the two main theories are wrong
if you enjoy this then don't forget to
smash the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
without the way welcome to the heavy
spoilers show
i'm your host definition now let's get
into what the bat symbol
really is okay so this was first brought
to my attention by simon waddle
who i've been talking back and forth
with over the last couple of months
simon was the guy that first spotted
that the pouches on batman's belt were
actually for nine millimeter eclipse
and from this we drew the conclusion
that his grand gun could be a repurposed
handgun
simon runs a twitter account called big
bad theory which i've linked below in
the description if you want to follow
him
and keep up to date with all that he's
up to i couldn't have done this video
without him so definitely show the guy
some love
now as for the bat symbol there's been
two main theories that have
predominantly been floating around
online
the first states that the bat symbol has
been reforged out of the gun
that was used to kill bruce wayne's
parents it's actually something that's
already popped up in batman mythos
but since its reveal no one's been able
to nail down
the make or model or where it even comes
from
so that leads us to our next theory
which is that it's a batarang
though this is a pretty cool idea when
you look at the chess piece itself
there's clearly a big gap running down
the middle of it
so in order to use it batman would have
to take it off
clip it together and then throw it which
it takes much longer than just punching
someone in the face
if the piece was loose there's also a
chance that it would fall off
and there's no real way to hold these
things together securely
especially with the angles that the
handles are at so
it just seems yeah pointless you start
to wonder
why not just one piece if that's the
case and
clearly the darts that he already has on
his wrist would be much better for what
he intends to do
so it doesn't really seem like either of
these theories are true and
we can pretty much put them on ice but
what is it
instead well we can now confirm that the
piece is actually a karambit
now this sounds crazy at first but i
think the further we get into the video
the more you'll see that it actually
lines up quite a lot we know from the
production team that batman will be
using
real-world items to get out his arsenal
and this has been seen in his bat suit
batmobile bat bike and more thus it
makes a lot of sense that he would make
the chess piece out of real world items
too
karambits are knives which are readily
available and they're actually used in a
lot of martial arts fighting
originally they were created as an
agricultural tool however
over the centuries they've become used
more and more in self-defense
and combat the design actually
originates from indonesia
and is based upon a tiger claw we know
from batman's long and rich history
that before becoming the dark knight
bruce traveled the world picking up many
martial arts styles
and learning the ins and outs of
specific weapons this of course was
shown in his batarangs which are based
on shurikens
and in his smoke bombs which he famously
got from the league of shadows
the knife has appeared in john wick and
the raid 2 and if you've ever seen them
up
close then you'll know it's very very
deadly
now the first thing that you might be
saying is that well batman doesn't
really use knives
and that's a fair point however he does
use a wealth of bladed weapons
such as the batarangs and even his arm
guards have blades on them too
obviously though i know you and you want
more evidence
and simon was actually kind enough to
put together an image with his symbol
and the karambits placed into it
so that we can see everything lines up
typically karambits have a thumb holder
so that you can easily keep a hold of
them as you flip the knife around your
opponent
this is one of the aspects that makes
the knife so deadly as it can be used
quickly
and allow you to change your grip a bit
without twisting your hands or wrists
here we see that the thumb holder isn't
present however there are certain quran
bits that are made with a loop of thread
to allow the piece to move in and out of
the weapon quickly
either that or he could have the thumb
loop separate and attached to his belt
now simon actually sent me a breakdown
of the entire symbol itself
and what each piece is which have turned
into a lovely
lovely little graphic that i hope you
enjoy now firstly we can see the
sharpened edge of the cymbal
does indeed look like a blade with this
side clearly being different to the more
blunt aspects of the chest symbol
we can assume that this side is sharp
for a specific reason
and thus it adds a lot of weight to the
idea that this is indeed a knife
above it is a specialized magnet and
this may be used to either attach it to
his back belt
or the aforementioned thumb loops
however it also may be there to lock
into the chest
this magnet would hold it in place
whilst batman busts up some heads
and allow him to place them back into
the piece without worrying about
which one's going where and whether it's
on the right side or not
now the fact that there's a locking
mechanism really makes me think that
this could be interchangeable
and that batman may have several of
these that he can put in and take out
depending on whether he loses it whilst
out crime fighting
or you know if it just gets stuck in
killer crocs head or something
this is given further away by the fact
that there's a belt clip also on the
karambit itself
this makes me think that he may already
have other karambits on his belt
so if he loses the one currently on his
chest he can just unclip it
and then put them back into the chest
piece to make sure that he has a
replacement
we all know batman loves putting bat
symbols on everything
he even likes branding people sometimes
so i've no doubt that he would keep a
spare
lying around just in case now batman
hasn't used knives that much in the
comics
and i can already hear people out there
saying that batman just wouldn't have it
as a weapon
because it's too deadly at this point
though we still don't know whether
batman will kill in this universe
and on the whole let's be honest the
films tend to lean more towards him
being a murderer than not i always
prefer my caped crusader to not be a
caped killer
however these are knives and yet though
they can be deadly at times
that doesn't mean they always are batman
will likely be going against bigger
opponents down the line
so he may have these as a backup plan
just in case
i personally wouldn't want to go against
someone like solomon grundy with just my
fists and a couple of smoke bombs so it
does make sense to keep
sharper weapons lying around batman also
uses explosives
such as his gel from the arkham games
and bombs which he's used against robots
and bigger opponents
thus he is ready to use things that can
potentially kill should it come down to
it
and as i said earlier we still don't
know how reeves is going to tackle it
now since posting this simon has had a
couple of people argue with him
including some that still think it's a
batarang however he has replied by
saying
i've heard that but i don't buy it it
would be
a very over designed piece of tech for
such a simple function
that results in it being discarded
completely
batman has a version of proto batarangs
in the form of both shurikens
strapped to his arms and i uh now
i completely agree with this sorry about
my voice there now i actually think that
batman
would have this on his chest just in
case he needed to whip him out
during a big fight on top of all this it
looks like batman himself
may actually be protecting his own body
against knife attacks
now huge shout outs to twitter account
bat source for also noticing that
batman's armor is actually shaped pretty
much like a swat team members
whether it's the shoulder pads or the
chest piece itself
it all seems to be designed around the
notion that batman is going to be going
head to head with some heavy hitters
in swat team usage they protect
particularly well against bullets
but also knives and thus it makes sense
that if batman is going to be going
against someone carrying blades
that he would be equipped to deal with
them himself so
in summary i'm really settled on this
being the case now
as i think it lines up with what we know
about the production of the movie itself
and also the direction that matt reeves
is taking the movie
it's been said that this will be a
darker more grounded batman that is
rooted in reality
and thus to me it makes sense for him to
take real world weapons and bring them
to his arsenal
the fact that the karambit is a weapon
that was developed in the east
also lines up with bruce traveling the
world and learning specific martial arts
methods
so i think everything sort of falls in
place when you start to put it under
scrutiny
obviously i'm sure we've got a lot to
talk about so i'd love to hear your
thoughts on this
make sure you comment below and let me
know do you still think it's joe chill's
gun
or a batarang or do you actually agree
with our analysis
i'll leave that in your hands and try
and reply to as many comments as i can
again huge shout outs to simon and make
sure you follow big bat theory on
twitter
for more posts like this if you want
something else to watch that's dc
related
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of zack snyder's justice com
panel
as we go over the clips and discuss
everything that you need to know about
the black suit
and what was said during the discussion
don't forget that every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning the mcu infinity saga
box set
is leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on if you want to support
the channel and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter if not
though thank you for making it until the
end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you